it led me to understand why life makes
it so complicated the complexity is the
robustness of
[Music]
life let's talk about um the sort of
Road leading up to the to the modeling
of the cardiovascular cells you'll have
to indulge me in this I assume you're
all interested but if not I I want to
hear about this I mean how did you end
up coming on to this idea of modeling it
was so revolutionary at the time
well it it it was Gish you know the the
the modeling that been done previously
was phenomenal um Alan hodkin and Andrew
Huxley um they received the Nobel Prize
uh in um physiology and Medicine in 1963
for the work they did in
1952 which was modeling nerve with a set
of differential equations um describing
the movements of the protein
Transporters I mean just phenomenal that
that length of time ago people were able
to do that they were ingenious I was
just a student um in
1958 so just six years later and I'd
struggle through that paper the 1952
paper is is is phenomenal I struggled
through it because I didn't really know
calculus at that time and I was so taken
by the idea you you can make biology be
like physics
you know the physicists are Computing
the movements of the planets we can
compute the movements of the molecules
and could we get the heartbeat out of it
well I was doing work with um a very
interesting biologist or physiologist
Otto hutter who had escaped from Vienna
when Hitler marched in well actually he
escaped before he marched in which is
very good because he he got to England
and became a professor at University
College London I became his graduate
student and he introduced me to
measuring potassium currents through the
membranes of cardiac cells which we did
and we identified two particular
potassium channels I then wondered you
know could it be that those equations
that Alan hodkin and Andrew Huxley had
developed for reproducing the electrical
activity of nerve could be modified with
the equation I was developing for those
potassium channels in the heart and
would that explain why the heart beats
like this because we need to
know and
so I asked is there a calculator well
yes they showed me a Bruns Vega
calculator I tell you it was it was a
machine you dialed numbers on it you
dialed another number over here and you
multiplied the two by going crunch
crunch and if you were clever at this
and do it quick quickly enough and wrote
the answers down and then used it to do
your Integrations well in about 10 years
time you might compute about two seconds
of activity in the heart so I well this
is no good I need a thesis rather
earlier than that um so I went to the
Guardians of what then was an extremely
precious machine the Mercury um for
anti- mercury computer which was a valve
computer the valves rather like what you
see in some amp amplifiers those special
amplifiers that high-i people like to um
use um
they were very suspicious of a biologist
of all people coming to them and asking
for time on this Extraordinary Machine
um most of the people who came to them
were of course x-ray crystallographers
people doing astronomy uh or particle
physics there were the three that I
remember very clearly um and the first
reaction was you you don't know enough
programming and you certainly don't seem
to know enough mathematics they were
quite right so I crept into the back of
the lectures given to the engineers in
mathematics I went up a learning curve
as fast as I could I went back to the
Guardians of the Mercury computer and
said well I you know I've written at
least a few lines of code you know could
you give me time they did they said well
you'll need about 2
hours and yes we can afford to hours
will give you from 2 to
4:
a.m. oh well that's when I destroyed my
Cadian Rhythm but there's another story
um anyway the fact was that simply
putting in those equations for the
potassium channels that I'd worked on
with Otto
Hatter out came
Rhythm and I remember talking with a a
physics Orient ented biophysicist at
University College London Ralph
niderer and he was also working on the
heart and the conversation went roughly
like this he of course was Far senior to
me I was just a young student he said
Dennis I think one of the biggest issues
in understanding the heart is what
causes its
Rhythm I thought
well I I've just shown
that but could I bring myself to talk to
that senior person and say but I think
I've just done
it I just felt so small and yet what I'd
found was what makes this happen well
now yes and no I mean it
worked um but what we found out much
later I it takes around 50 to 60 years
to work out the whole story is it ain't
that simple two potassium channels and
one sodium channel is by no means um not
enough because if that was what your
heart was doing at the moment most of
you have been dead before you came to
listen to me because it's extremely
fragile and what we know of course is
that nature builds in all kinds of
redundancy to give strength to the
system so that it doesn't fail if one
gene drops out or a mutation happens
most of the time uh that doesn't happen
thank goodness so there there's a rough
story of how I got into using
computers I I love that story but also
talking about this redundancy let's take
a little side step into your personal
life if we may yeah you know being a
scientist can be quite demoralizing at
times you already alluded to the fact
that sometimes you feel like the
smallest Cog in a very large machine it
so what What mechanisms do you feel
helped you get through your time in
Academia that made you feel feel more
robust gave you those robust Pathways
support mechanisms you sort of alluded
to music I assume there were people so
yeah what did what were your mechanisms
of support well I think that's a bit
like um the monk in the monastery
wondering whether he can go through with
this and all his vows and so on because
you know working in a science lab is
like that isn't it you just keep going
you know and most of the time you make
nose down the discoveries at all you you
keep going um no what broke out for me
about 20 years
later um was attraction to
music and very particularly because I
had by then bought an incredible old
ruin of a house in the south of France
where I found they don't speak just
French they speak the language of the
medieval chadors The
oxyon Poets I there there's there's
there's my vocation I will learn all of
this so I joined music groups down there
to uh work out how to sing this language
and so on I now run a music group called
The Oxford trors we perform Wow We
performed in the sheldonian theater on
the 6th of June I think it was this year
to a crowd of about 500 I mean imagine
it a language nobody knows well I know
it and there a few others in England
know it singing songs that most people
don't know about and we get beautiful
audiences for me I think that was the
break from the monastic life if I can
call it that of trying to be a really
good scientist just keeping going and
starting to find another aspect of life
but then it informed my science why is
my first Book on a systems biological
theme called the music of life and why
is the next book called dance to the
tune of life which is published six
years ago by Cambridge University press
sorry for the advert but there we are um
you could probably bu exactly the book
book yes it's a very good book Richard
Dawkins told me it was a very good book
and we we totally disagree on everything
except that we both written good books
now anyway
what I felt once I'd learned that that
first model built 60 years ago was very
fragile I it led me to understand why
life makes it so complicated the
complexity is the robustness of life you
wouldn't fly an aircraft if you knew
that the only system that will control
the flight of that aircraft was a single
computer program there is a backup and
that's what nature does all the time now
now why is this related to music it's
simply that when you when you play an
instrument or you learn how to sing you
are producing a process the process
itself is the performance it isn't in
the
score well it is Schubert probably had
it in his head but that that that's the
point you see it is actually performance
that gives what is important and I I
interpret biology to be that the way to
understand the way in which genes play
their role in the organism is that they
are actually caused to dance to the tune
we play now it's a curious way of
putting it but if you read my book you
might become convinced to continue
watching this video click the link in
the top left or in the description below
or visit I a.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today biggest
ideas